psych is a project launched by you in
1984 and still is active today
whose goal is to assemble a knowledge
base that spans the basic concepts and
rules about how the world works
in other words it hopes to capture
common sense knowledge
which is a lot harder than it sounds
can you elaborate on this mission and
maybe perhaps speak to the various
sub-goals within this mission
when
i was a faculty member in the computer
science department at stanford
my colleagues and i
did research in
all sorts of artificial intelligence
programs so natural language
understanding programs robots expert
systems
and so on
and we kept hitting the very same brick
wall
our systems would have
impressive early successes
and so if your only goal was academic
namely to
get enough material to write a journal
article
that might actually suffice but if
you're really trying to get ai
then you have to somehow get past the
brick wall and the brick wall was
the programs didn't have
what we would call common sense they
didn't have general world knowledge they
didn't really understand what they were
doing what they were saying what they
were being asked
and so very much like a um
a clever dog performing tricks we could
get them to do tricks but they never
really understood what they were doing
sort of like when
you get a dog to fetch your morning
newspaper
the dog might do that successfully but
the dog has no idea what a newspaper is
or what it says or anything like that
what does it mean to understand
something can you maybe elaborate on
that a little bit is it is understand an
action of like combining little things
together like through inference or is
understanding the wisdom you gain over
time that forms and knowledge i think of
understanding more like a um
think of it more like the ground you
stand on
which
could be very shaky could be very unsafe
but most of the time is not because
underneath it is more ground
and eventually you know rock and and
other things but
layer after layer after layer
that solid foundation is there and you
rarely need to think about it you rarely
need to count on it but occasionally you
do
and
i've never used this analogy before so
bear with me but i think the same thing
is true in in terms of getting computers
to understand things which is
uh you ask
a computer a question for instance alexa
or
some robot or something and
maybe it gets the right answer
but if you were asking that of a human
you could also say things like why
or how might you be wrong about this or
something like that and the person you
know would would answer you and you know
it might be a little annoying if you
have a small child and they keep asking
why questions in series eventually you
get to the point where you throw up your
hands and say i don't know it's just the
way the world is
but for many layers you actually have
that that layered
solid
foundation of support so that when you
need it
you can count on it and when do you need
it well when things are unexpected when
you come up against a situation which is
novel for instance when you're driving
it may be fine to have a small program a
small set of rules that cover you know
99 of the cases but that one percent of
the time when something strange happens
um you really need to draw on common
sense for instance um my wife and i were
driving recently
and there was a trash truck in front of
us
and um i guess they had packed it too
full and the back exploded and trash
bags went everywhere
and we had to you know make a split
second decision are we going to slam on
our brakes are we going to swerve into
another lane
are we going to just run it over
because there are cars all around us
and you know in front of us was a large
trash bag and we know what we throw away
in trash bags probably not a safe thing
to run over
um over on the the left was um a bunch
of fast food restaurant um trash bags
and it's like oh well those things are
just like styrofoam and leftover food
we'll run over that and so that was a
safe thing for us to to do now that's
the kind of thing that's going to happen
maybe once in your life
and
but the point is that there's almost no
telling
what little bits of knowledge about the
world you might actually need um in some
situations which were unforeseen
but see when you sit on that mountain
or that ground that goes deep of
knowledge
in order to make a split-second decision
about fast food trash or random trash
from the back of a
trash truck
uh
you need to be able to leverage that
ground you stand on someone it's not
merely
you know it's not enough to just have a
lot of ground to stand on it's your
ability to leverage it to utilize in a
split like integrate it all together to
make that split second decision
and i i suppose
understanding isn't just
having uh
common sense knowledge to access
it's the act of accessing accessing it
somehow like correctly
um
filtering out the the parts of the
knowledge are not useful selecting only
the useful parts and uh
effectively making conclusive decisions
so let's tease apart
two different tasks really both of which
are incredibly important and even
necessary
um if you're going to have this in a
usable a useful usable fashion as
opposed to say like library books
sitting on a shelf right
and so on
where the knowledge might be there but
you know if a fire comes the books are
going to burn because they don't know
what's in them and they're just going to
sit there while they burn um so there
are two they're two
aspects of using the knowledge one is a
kind of a theoretical
how is it possible at all
and then the second aspect of what you
said is how can you do it quickly enough
so how can you do it at all is something
that philosophers have grappled with and
fortunately philosophers a hundred years
ago and even earlier
developed a kind of
formal language
like english
it's called
predicate logic or first order logic or
something like predicate calculus and so
on so there's a way of representing
things
in this formal language
which
enables a mechanical procedure to sort
of grind through
and algorithmically produce all of the
same logical
entailments all the same logical
conclusions that you or i would from
that same set of pieces of information
that are represented that way
um so
that that sort of raises
a couple questions one is how do you get
all this information from say
observations and english and so on into
this logical form right and secondly how
can you then efficiently
run these algorithms to actually get the
information you need in in the case i
mentioned in a tenth of a second rather
than say i'm in you know 10 hours or 10
000 years of computation
and those are both really important um
questions and like a corollary addition
to the first one is how many
such
things you need to gather for it to be
useful in certain contexts
so like what
in order you mention philosophers in
order to capture this world and
represent it
in a logical way and with a formal logic
like how many statements are required is
it five is it ten is it ten trillion is
it like that that's
as far as i understand is uh probably
still an open question it may forever be
an open question uh
just to say like definitively about
to describe the universe perfectly well
how many facts do you need okay
i i guess i'm going to disappoint you by
giving you an actual answer to your
question okay um well no this sounds
exciting
yes okay so so now we have like um three
three things to talk about we'll keep
adding more that's okay the first and
the third are related yes um so let's
leave the efficiency question aside for
now
so um how how does all this information
get represented in
logical form so that these algorithms
resolution theorem proving and other
algorithms can actually grind through
all the logical consequences of what you
said
and that ties into your question about
how many of these things do you need
because if the answer is small enough
then by hand you could write them out
one at a time
so
in
the
19 early
i held a meeting at stanford where i was
a
faculty member there
where we assembled um about half a dozen
of the smartest people i know
people like um
alan newell and marvin minsky and alan
kaye
and um
um a few others was firemen there by
chance because he he liked yours he
commented about your system yurisco at
the time no no he he wasn't part of this
meeting um but that's a heck of a
meeting anyway i think ed feigerman was
there i think um
um josh lederberg was there so we we
have um
all these different um smart people and
we were um we came together to
address the question
that that you raised which is if it's
important to represent common sense
knowledge and world knowledge in order
for ais to not be brittle
in order for ais not to just have the
veneer of intelligence well how many
pieces
of common sense how many if then rules
for instance would we have to actually
write in order to essentially cover what
what people expect
perfect strangers to already know about
the world
um i expected there would be an enormous
divergence of opinion um and computation
but amazingly everyone got an answer
which was around a million
and one person one person got the answer
um by saying well um look you can only
burn into human long-term memory a
certain number of things per unit time
like maybe one every 30 seconds or
something and other than that it's just
short-term memory and it flows away like
water and so on so by the time you're
say 10 years old or so
how many things could you possibly have
burned into your long-term memory and
it's like about a million
another person went a completely
different direction and said well if you
look at the number of words
in a
dictionary not a whole dictionary but
for someone to
essentially be considered to be fluent
in a language how many words would they
need to know and then about how many
things about each word would you have to
tell it and so they got to a million
that way
another another person said well let's
actually look at one single
short one volume desk encyclopedia
article
and so we'll look at you know what was
like a
a four paragraph article or something i
think about grebes grebes are a type of
waterfowl
and if we were going to sit there and
represent every single thing that was
there
how many assertions or rules or
statements would we have to write in
this logical language and so on and then
multiply that by all of the number of
articles that there were and so on so
all of these estimates came out with a
million
and so
if you do the math it turns out that
like oh well then maybe in
something like
person years
in one or two person centuries we could
actually get
this written down by hand
and
a marvelous
coincidence opportunity existed
right at that point in time the early
1980s there was something called the
japanese fifth generation computing
effort japan had threatened to do in
computing and ai and hardware what they
had just finished doing in consumer
electronics on the automotive industry
namely resting control away from the
united states and more generally away
from the west
and so america was scared
and congress did something that's how
you know it was a long time ago because
congress did something
congress passed something called the
national cooperative research act ncra
and what it said was hey all you big
american companies that's also how you
know it was a long time ago because they
were american companies rather than
multinational companies hey all you big
american companies
normally it would be an anti-trust
violation if you colluded on r d but we
promise for the next 10 years
we won't prosecute any of you if you do
that
to help combat this threat and so
overnight
the first two consortia research
consortia in america sprang up
both of them coincidentally in austin
texas
one called sematech focusing on hardware
chips and so on and then one called mcc
the microelectronics and computer
technology corporation focusing on more
on software on databases and ai and
natural language understanding and
things like that
and
i got the opportunity thanks to my
friend woody bledsoe
who was one of the people who founded
that to come and be its principal
scientist and he said you know
and he sent admiral bob inman who was
the person running mcc uh came and
talked to me and said look professor you
know you're talking about doing this
project it's going to involve
person centuries of effort
if you've only got a handful of graduate
students you do the math it's going to
take you like
you know
longer than the rest of your life to
finish this project but if you move to
the wilds of austin texas uh we'll put
10 times as many people on it and
you know you'll be done in
a few years and so that was pretty
exciting and so um i did that i
took my leave from stanford i came to to
austin i worked for mcc and
good news and bad news the bad news is
that all of us were off by an order of
magnitude
that it turns out what you need are tens
of millions of these
pieces of knowledge about um every day
sort of like um if you have a coffee cup
with stuff in it and you turn it upside
down the stuff in it's gonna fall out
so you need tens of millions of pieces
of knowledge like that even if you take
trouble to make each one as general as
it possibly could be
but
the good news was that thanks to um
initially the fifth generation effort
and then later
u.s government um agency funding and so
on we were able to get enough funding
not for um a couple person centuries of
time but for a couple person millennia
of time which is what we've spent since
1984 getting psych to contain
the tens of millions of rules that it
needs in order to really capture uh and
span uh sort of not all of human
knowledge but the things that you assume
other people know the things you count
on other people knowing
and
so by now we've done that
and the good news is since you've waited
38 years just about to talk to me
we're about at the
at the end of that process so most of
what we're doing now is not putting in
even what you would consider common
sense but more putting in
domain specific application specific
knowledge about
health care
in a certain hospital or about
oil
pipes getting clogged up or whatever the
applications happen to be so we've
almost come full circle and we're doing
things very much like the expert systems
of the 1970s and the 1980s except
instead of resting on nothing and being
brittle they're now resting on this
massive pyramid if you will this massive
lattice of common sense knowledge so
that when things go wrong when something
unexpected happens they can fall back on
more and more and more general
principles um eventually bottoming out
in things like um for instance if we
have a problem with the microphone one
of the things you'll do is unplug it
plug it in again and hope for the best
right because that's one of the general
pieces of knowledge you have in dealing
with electronic equipment or software
systems or
things like that is there a basic
principle like that like is it possible
to encode something that generally
captures this idea of
turn it off and turn it back on and see
if it fixes oh absolutely that's one of
the things that
that's like news that's actually one of
the fundamental
laws of nature i believe
i wouldn't i wouldn't call it a law it's
it's more like a um
it seems to work every time so it sure
sure is like looks like a law i don't
know so that um that basically um
covered the um the resources needed and
then we had to devise a method to
actually figure out well what are the
tens of millions of things that we need
to tell the system and for that we've
found a few
techniques which worked really well one
is to take um any piece of text almost
it could be an advertisement it could be
a transcript it could be a novel it
could be an article
and don't pay attention to the actual
type that's there the the black space on
the white page pay attention to the
complement of that the white space if
you will so what did the writer of this
sentence assume that the reader already
knew about the world for instance if
they used a pronoun
how did they figure out that why did
they think that you would be able to
understand what their intended referent
of that pronoun was if they used an
ambiguous word
how did they think that you would be
able to figure out what they meant by
that word
the other thing we look at is the gap
between one sentence and the next one
what are all the things that the writer
expected you to fill in and infer
occurred between the end of one sentence
and the beginning of the other so like
if the sentence says um
fred smith robbed the third national
bank period
he was sentenced to 20 years in prison
period well between the first sentence
and the second you're expected to infer
things like fred got caught fred
got arrested fred went to jail fred had
a trial fred was found guilty
and so on if my next sentence starts out
with something like the judge dot dot
dot then you assume it's the judge at
his trial if my next sentence starts out
something like the arresting officer dot
dot dot you assume that it was the
police officer who arrested him after he
committed the crime and so on so um
that's it those are two techniques for
getting um
that knowledge the the other thing we
sometimes look at is uh sort of like
fake news or uh sort of humorous um
onion headlines or
headlines in
the weekly world news if you know what
that is or the national enquirer where
it's like oh we don't believe this then
we introspect on why don't we believe it
so there are things like um
b17 lands on the moon you know it's like
why don't we what do we know about the
world that causes us to believe that
that's just silly or uh something like
that or um another thing we look for are
contradictions um where with things
which can't both be true um and we say
to like what is it that we know that
causes us to know that both of these
can't be true at the same at the same
time for instance in one of the weekly
world news
editions in one article it talked about
how elvis was cited um you know even
though he was uh you know getting on in
years and so on and another article in
the same one talked about people seeing
elvis ghost
okay so it's like why why do we believe
that at least one of these articles you
know must be wrong
um and so on so um so we have a series
of techniques like that that enable our
people um and by now uh we have about 50
people working full time on this and
have for for decades so we've put in the
thousands of person years of effort
we've built up these tens of millions of
rules we constantly
police the system to make sure that
we're saying things as generally as we
possibly can
so
um you don't want to say things like um
no mouse is also a moose
because if you said things like that
then you'd have to add another one or
two or three zeros onto the number of
assertions you'd actually have to have
so
at some point we generalize things more
and more and we get to a point where we
say oh yeah for any two
biological taxons if we don't know
explicitly that one is a generalization
of another then almost certainly they're
disjoint a member of one is not going to
be a member of the other and so on so
and the same thing with the elvis and
the ghost it has nothing to do with
elvis it's more about
human nature and then the the mortality
and well
in general things are not both alive and
dead at the same time yeah and unless
special cats in in theoretical physics
examples well that raises um a couple
important points well that's the onion
headline situation type of thing okay
sorry but no no so so what you bring up
is this really important point of like
well how do you handle exceptions and
inconsistencies
and so on um and one of the hardest
lessons for us to learn it took us about
five years to to really grit our teeth
and
learn to love it
is we had to give up global consistency
so the knowledge base can no longer be
consistent so this is a kind of scary
thought i grew up watching star trek and
anytime a computer was inconsistent it
would either freeze up or explode or
take over the world or something bad
would happen
or if you come from a mathematics
background
once you can prove false you can prove
anything so that's not good
and so on so
that's why on the old knowledge based
systems were all very very consistent
but the trouble is that
by and large our models of the world the
way we talk about the world and so on
there are all sorts of inconsistencies
that creep in here and there
that will sort of kill some attempt to
build some enormous globally consistent
knowledge base and so what we had to
move to
was a system of local consistency so a
good analogy is you know that the
surface of the earth is more or less
spherical
globally
but you live your life every day as
though the surface of the earth were
flat
you know when you're talking to someone
in australia you don't think of them as
being oriented upside down to you when
you're planning a trip you know even if
it's a thousand miles away
you may think a little bit about time
zones but you rarely think about the
curvature of the earth and so on and for
most purposes you can live your whole
life without really worrying about that
because the earth is locally flat
in much the same way the psych knowledge
base is divided up into almost like
tectonic plates which are individual
contexts and each context is more or
less consistent but there can be
small inconsistencies at the boundary
between one context and the next one and
so on and so by the time you move say 20
contexts over there could be glaring
inconsistencies so eventually you get
from the normal modern real world
context that we're in right now to
something you know like um road runner
cartoon context where physics is very
different and in fact life and death are
very different because no matter how
many times he's killed you know the
coyote comes back in the next scene and
and so on
so um that that was a hard lesson to
learn and we had to make sure that our
representation language the way we the
way that we actually encode the
knowledge and represent it was
expressive enough that we could talk
about things being true in one context
and false in another things that are
true at one time and false in another
things that are true let's say in one
region like one country but false in
another things that are true in one
person's belief system but false in
another person's belief system things
that are true at one level of
abstraction and false in another for
instance at one level of abstraction
you think of this table as a solid
object but at you know down at the
atomic level it's mostly empty space and
so on so then that's fascinating and but
it puts a lot of
pressure on context to do a lot of work
so you say tectonic plates is it
possible to formulate contacts that are
general and big
that do this kind of capture of
knowledge bases or do you then get
turtles on top of turtles again where
there's just a huge number of contexts
so it's good you ask that question
because
you're pointed in the right direction
which is
you want context to be
first class objects
in your system's knowledge base in
particular in sykes knowledge base um
and by first class object i mean that
it should we should be able to have
psych think about and talk about and
reason about
one context or another context the same
way it reasons about coffee cups and
tables and people and fishing and so on
and so contexts are just terms in its
language just like the ones i mentioned
and so psych can reason about
context context can arrange
hierarchically and so on
and so you can say things about
let's say
things that are true
in the modern era things that are true
in a particular year would then be a
sub-context of
the the things that are true in um
abroad let's say a century or a
millennium or something like that things
that are true in austin texas
are generally going to be a
specialization of
things that are true in texas which is
going to be a specialization of things
that are true in the united states and
so on
and so you don't have to say things over
and over over again
at all these levels you just say things
at the most general level that it
applies to and you only have to say it
once and then it essentially inherits to
all these more specific
contexts just a slightly technical
question is this inherent in an
inheritance a tree or a graph oh you
definitely have to think of it as a
graph um so we could talk about for
instance why the japanese fifth
generation computing effort failed there
were about half a dozen different
reasons one of the reasons they failed
was because they tried to represent
knowledge as a tree
rather than as a graph
and so each node in their
representation
could only have one parent
node so if you had a table that was a
wooden object a black object a flat
object and so you have to choose one and
that's the only parent it could have
when of course you know depending on
what it is you need to reason about it
sometimes it's important to know that
it's made out of wood like if we're
talking about a fire sometimes it's
important to know that it's flat if
we're talking about resting something on
it and so on so um
one of the one of the problems was that
they wanted a kind of dewey decimal
numbering system
for all of their concepts which meant
that each node could only have at most
10 children and each node could only
have one parent
and
while that does enable the dewey decimal
type
numbering of concepts labeling of
concepts
it prevents you from representing all
the things you need to about
objects in our in our world and that was
one of the things which
they never were able to overcome and i
think that was one of the main reasons
that that project failed so we'll return
to some of the doors you've opened but
if we can go back to that room in 1984
around there with marvin minsky yeah
by the way i should mention that marvin
wouldn't do his estimate until someone
brought him an envelope so that he could
literally do a back of the envelope
calculations to come up with his number
well because i i feel like
the conversation in that room is an
important one
you know this this how um
sometimes science is done in this way a
few people get together and plant the
seed of ideas and they reverberate
throughout history
and some some kind of uh dissipating
disappear and some
you know drake equation and you know
they you know seems like a meaningless
equation somewhat meaningless but i
think it drives and motivates a lot of
scientists and when the aliens finally
show up
that equation will get even more uh
valuable because then we'll get be able
to us in the long arc of history the
drake equation
will prove to be
quite useful
i think in that same way a conversation
of
just how many facts
are required to capture the basic common
sense knowledge of the world that's a
fascinating question i want to
distinguish between what you think of as
facts
and the kind of things that we represent
so
um
we we map to and essentially make sure
that psych has the ability to as it were
read and access the kind of facts you
might find say
in wikidata or stated in a wikipedia
article or something like that so what
we're representing the things that we
need a small number of tens of millions
of are more like rules of thumb rules of
good guessing things which are usually
true and which help you to make sense of
the
facts that are on sort of sitting off in
some database or some other more static
story so they're almost like platonic
forms so like when you read stuff on
wikipedia that's going to be like
projections of those ideas you read an
article about the fact that elvis died
that's a projection of the idea that uh
humans are mortal and like you know
very few wikipedia articles will write
humans are immortal
exactly and that's what i meant about
ferreting out the unstated things in
texas what are all the things that were
assumed and so those are things like um
if you have a problem with something
turning it off and on um often fixes it
for reasons we don't really understand
and we're not happy about or
people can't be both alive and dead at
the same time and or water flows
downhill if you search online for water
flowing uphill and water flowing
downhill you'll find more references for
water flowing uphill because it's used
as a kind of a
metaphorical reference for some unlikely
thing because of course everyone already
knows that water flows downhill so why
would anyone bother saying that do you
have a word you prefer
because we said facts isn't the right
word is there a word like concepts i
would say assertions
assertions or rules because i'm not
talking about rigid rules but rules of
thumb but assertions um is a nice one
that covers um all of these things yeah
as a programmer to me a cert
has a very uh dogmatic authoritarian
feel to them i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry okay but assertions works
you